-Welcome back, everybody.
It is time for "Screen Grabs."
Here we go.
-♪ Make me wanna screen grab ♪
-Now, these are
some weird, funny things
that you guys found
on the Internet
or took a picture of
in real life,
and then sent it in to us.
The first screen grab
was sent in
by Laura in Newburgh, New York.
She was trying to read
an article on Apple News.
Okay, let's see
what it was here.
"Subscriptions Are Getting
Out of Hand.
Here's How to Manage Them."
Yeah.
And then down here it says,
"This story requires
a subscription to Apple News+."
[ Laughter ]
It's getting out of hand.
This next screen grab
was sent in by Sarah Farrelman
in Rochester, New York.
She was looking at Facebook and
spotted some furniture for sale.
Look at this.
It says, "Designer crackled
furniture set. $850."
-Oh, my God. Ohh.
-"Designer crackled"?
Let me guess.
You're the designer? Yeah.
"I've been designing this
for 20 years."
-"I designed it right here."
-This is the old couch.
-"My butt is the designer."
-Next screen grab was sent in by
Petra Kolb in London, England.
Hey, we love that people
watch in London.
[ Cheers and applause ]
She was watching Rachel Maddow,
who, I guess, is very into yoga.
Watch the way
these two pictures added up.
Wow. She's very flexible.
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
-This next screen grab
was sent in by Pammy Salmon.
-Pammy Salmon.
-Pammy Salmon?
-Wow. That's a lovely name.
-That's a fantastic name.
Pammy Salmon.
Right here in New York City.
Pammy Salmon's out there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-She googled "common COVID
questions in New York City."
Okay?
And here's what she found.
Here's -- "How much does a
COVID-19 test cost in New York?"
"Do you have to quarantine
if traveling to New York?"
"Does antibody tests
have a cost?"
And then, "Are New York City
divorce courts open?"
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-Ohh. Oh.
That's number five.
-Yeah. It's been a rough one.
Our next screen grab was sent in
by Meredith Messinger
in Boise, Idaho.
She found a website that will
print custom photos on pillows.
-Oh.
-I love that.
Here's the example
that they gave.
Wow.
[ Laughter ]
-Nightmare.
-Yeah. Wow.
-"Let me out!
Let me out of here!"
-It talks to you, as well?
The pillow. You press it?
-I'm assuming that it's stuck --
"Let me out, please!
I'm trapped in the other zone."
-This next one was sent in
by Amy McCloud
in Montecito, California.
She spotted someone
selling a rug online,
and they had a very interesting
way of showing how big it was.
-Oh, great.
-"Just lay down there, honey.
Honey, just lay down on the rug
just so I can get the..."
[ Laughter ]
"Honey, just lay down on the rug
so we can see
how big the rug is.
My wife's about 5'4", so..."
[ Laughter ]
Can we see that picture --
Can we see it again?
I hope it's not --
I hope it's not blood.
-Looks like she's --
-I hope that's not blood.
Geez.
-"Quick. Get a..."
-It's like a "Dateline" episode.
-"Get a picture of the rug
before the blood
spreads all the way."
-[ Laughs ]
-"Don't move."
-I gotta see it again.
I just think
that's so funny, man.
[ "Law & Order" tones play ]
-No, but, like --
Why be face-down?
-"I don't want to show my face."
-Yeah.
This next one was sent in
by Sue Shugert
in Hendersonville,
North Carolina.
They had a snow day,
so she was going to take
the kids to a local
tubing place...
-Oh.
-...and saw this right here.
That's cool. It looks fun.
And then it says up here...
"Please read. We are closed
today due to the snow.
Thanks."
[ Laughter ]
-"Shut it down!"
-Makes sense.
Next screen grab was sent in
by Jessica Swafford
in Wyoming, Michigan.
She was browsing Facebook on her
phone and spotted a great deal.
"Gently used GE dryer. $250."
[ Laughter ]
Barely.
-Gently.
-Barely. Gently.
-It's gently used.
-It was gently lowered in the
middle of the woods somewhere.
-Gently took off the front.
-Yeah.
-And took out the insides.
-We're down to our last one.
This is from Shawn Smith
in Chicago.
He was watching
the show "Younger."
It's a good show, and
he spotted a background extra
playing a monk
that he thinks looks like me.
Let me take a look at this.
[ Laughter ]
That's insane!
Let me see this here.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Not bad?
It does kind of look like me.
That's all the time we have
for "Screen Grabs."
If you have a funny screen grab,
e-mail it to us at
screengrabs@tonightshow.com.
We might put it on the show.
Stick around.